the falcon and the winter soldier is a
marvel project that's layered with
meaning
dealing with themes of legacy history
race and shared humanity
if you're paying close attention you may
hear some lines of dialogue between all
of the fight scenes
that mean more than you know one of the
central themes explored throughout the
falcon and the winter soldier
revolves around captain america's shield
and what it symbolizes to the rest of
the world
to bucky barnes the shield represents
family it is his last remaining link to
steve rogers and the world he knew in
the 1940s
before hydra turned him into the winter
soldier to john walker the shield
represents the high expectations he has
to live up to
as a new captain america and a symbol of
hope for his country
to carly morgan foul the shield is a
symbol of a bygone era
and the monument to the people whose
stories were erased from history like
isaiah bradley the black soldier bucky
reveals to sam
as a fellow recipient of the serum cap
shield means different things to
different people
but only sam seems to view it for what
it really is on its own it's just a
symbol
symbols
are nothing without the women and men
that give them meaning steve's legacy
defines a shield until it falls into
john walker's hands
when the new captain america uses it to
kill one of the flag smashers the image
of the bloody shield represents a rapid
fall from grace because of the man who
wields it
sam finally reclaiming the shield
indicates redemption for its damaged
reputation
as he redefines what it means to be
captain america
to the majority of the world sam wilson
is a hero he is a falcon
a member of the avengers who faced
thanos the mad titan
and his army in infinity war and endgame
it could be argued that this heroism is
part of sam's nature
he is a rescuer swooping in to save the
day sam's first scene in the falcon in
the winter soldier features him rescuing
someone from winter soldier villain
george batroc
aka batroc the leaper sam's sister sarah
comments on her
brother's heroic character in the same
episode when he vows to help save their
family's votes and erase their financial
struggles with the bank
to the rescue huh when fans first meet
sam in captain america the winter
soldier
he explains that prior to aiding steve
in the fight against hydra
he worked as a pararescueman for the
united states air force
this establishes falcon as someone who
dedicates his life to rescuing other
people
later during a conversation with his
sister in episode 5
sam talks about wanting to make a
positive difference in the world
regardless of the boundaries and
expectations placed on his shoulders by
society
this earlier fund moment between the
wilson siblings shows just how much
sarah understands her brother
and why sam is the perfect person to
pick up the mantle of captain america
like steve rogers before him sam is a
hero always ready to fly to the rescue
isn't this suit it comes with
expectations brother
you can't just punch your hair problems
anymore
if this episode two line from the mars
sounds familiar when he says it to john
walker
there's a good reason for that it's a
callback to a similar call for reason
in captain america civil war steve
you know what's about to happen do you
really want to punch your way out of
this one
indeed both versions of captain america
could have occasionally done better by
talking things through
instead of rushing in fist first lamar's
warning foreshadows john walker's
descend throughout the series
culminating in the moments when he kills
one of carly's allies in public
this is the moment that separates walker
from steve rogers
and establishes that he isn't worthy of
being captain america
when bucky falls from the train to his
supposed death in captain america the
first avenger
steve doesn't beat zola to death with
the shield he keeps his mind on the
mission
even for an avenger personal vengeance
isn't always the answer
it's a lesson john walker could stand to
learn as well as the mcu moves
forward maybe we'll see if he does john
walker's right when it comes to one
thing
the super soldier serum isn't all it's
cracked up to be
most people injected with variants of
the serum suffered side effects becoming
unstable or even dying
that serum doesn't exactly have a great
track record no offense
the serum itself was used by hydra who
gave it to bucky and several other
winter soldier candidates
the other soldiers featured in civil war
are revealed to have been too unstable
for hydra to control
and were frozen in cryostasis until zemo
killed them
with the exception of steve rogers and
isaiah bradley the serum seems to have
had negative effects on almost everyone
who's taken it
from the red skull to cardi morgenthau
and john walker either physically
harming them or bringing out their worst
qualities
the serum amplifies everything that is
inside so
good becomes great bet
becomes worse walker's line shows that
he understands what a risk the serum
poses
this doesn't stop him from taking it
however highlighting how powerless he
feels without the enhanced super
strength steve rogers had
walker doesn't seem to fully realize
however that steve was more than a
strong soldier
he was a good man and the serum brought
out the best in him
both of them were chosen to be captain
america for different reasons
walker may be a perfect soldier but
steve was a good man
bucky barnes spent more of his life as a
winter soldier than he did as himself
bucky spends over 50 years as a winter
soldier programmed to kill with his
memory wipes between bouts of cryostasis
until he meets steve again in 2014
drawing captain america the winter
soldier
bucky tries to shed the winter soldier's
identity but it continues to haunt him
and it isn't until his exile in wakanda
that the programming is finally lifted
from his mind
even then the winter soldier remains a
familiar role for him to play
zemo says as much when bucky pretends to
be his former self in madrid
preying on bucky's insecurities about
whether he's changed after all
didn't take much for him to fall back
into form
what made steve the perfect candidate
for the super soldier serum
he says it best himself during captain
america the first avenger
i don't want to kill anyone i don't like
bullies
i don't care where they're from steve
knows what it means to be the little guy
literally it's a history that makes him
more empathetic and there's something
other super soldiers than the mcu don't
seem to have experienced
the serum never corrupted steve touche
but there has never been another steve
rogers has there when zemu makes this
oddly respectful comment about steve
at the same time he's unknowingly
referencing the original captain
america's similarities with sam
sam is another empathetic character in
the marvel cinematic universe
he leads counselling sessions in captain
america the winter soldier
understands carly's perspective and
tries to reach out to her
and even helps bucky find some
resolution there isn't another steve
rogers to pick up the shield but there
is sam wilson
and steve clearly understood that john
walker's defeated the hands of the dora
melange proves to be the final straw
that pushes him towards the super
soldier serum
in the series fourth episode throughout
the falcon and the winter soldier walker
struggles to live up to the legacy of
his predecessor
many characters including sam bucky and
zemo
acknowledge that steve was a rare man
and affected by the serum's negative
side effects
steve's shoes are hard to fill even for
a veteran as decorated as walker
walker struggles to go toe to toe
against carly and the flax smashers but
it's his lust to the dora melange that
humiliates him and drives him to take
action
simply put he's totally humiliated to be
defeated by them
they weren't even super soldier even
without superpowers adorama lager defeat
jon in a fight
their combat training and proficiency
with vibranium weaponry are unparalleled
this last fuels walker's decision to
take the serum so he can feel less
inadequate
but what walker fails to understand is
that steve was more than just his super
powers
instead of trying to diminish and
overpower the dora malay
steve would have approached him with
more respect and diplomacy this relates
to lamar's earlier line about walker
trying to punch his way out of
situations
a near impossible feat when faced with
the warrior women of wakanda
although sam and bucky struggled to get
along initially their relationship
evolves throughout the falcon and the
winter soldier
as they begin to open up to each other
and understand the others point of view
despite the banter there's no doubt that
by the time they confront carly at mama
donia's funeral
they are partners just as they were with
steve rogers john walker unknowingly
marks an important milestone in this
relationship when he goes bucky with a
comment about sam
your partner needs backup in there
do you really want his blood on your
hands it's one of many things in this
series that forces bucky a notoriously
closed off individual
to confront the uncomfortable reality
that he actually cares about sam
sam can handle himself but the threat of
a super soldier like carly isn't to be
taken lightly
walker plays on sam's vulnerability as
well as bucky's guilt
as a former winter soldier couldn't live
with himself if sam's death was added to
his conscience
if any line in the series proves why sam
wilson should be captain america
it's his remark to zemo following his
confrontation with carly
in episode 4. blood isn't always the
solution
zemo argues that carly has become too
radicalized to reason with
in his eyes she is a danger to society
and needs to be killed
some points out the hypocrisy of zemo's
absolutist perspective
super soldiers cannot be allowed
to exist isn't that how gods talk
it could be argued that zemo's
intentions aren't necessarily evil
though he possesses a ruthless streak
that makes him a dangerous person
like thanos zemo doesn't shy away from
killing in his attempts to serve what he
sees as a greater good
the mad titan believed that the universe
had to lose half of its population to
survive
and zemo makes it clear that he views
all super soldiers as a threat to human
existence
that must be exterminated sam
understands that punching your way out
of things
isn't the default resolution to conflict
he reasons with kali and sympathizes
with the flag smashes fight
but makes it clear that he can't get
behind their violent methods
unlike john walker who responds to
lamar's death by drawing blood
sam keeps us calm and considers all the
options
fans are introduced to isaiah bradley in
the series second episode
but it isn't until episode 5 that his
story is truly told
after taking the shield from john walker
it seems as though sam intends to give
the shield to isaiah
but isaiah has other ideas those stars
and stripes dome
mean nothing good to me isaiah bradley
and steve rogers share more similarities
than just the serum
while speaking with sam isaiah reveals
why he was sent to prison
fellow super soldiers were captured by
enemy forces prompting officials to
abandon them with the intention of
blowing up the facility where they were
detained
to destroy any evidence isaiah refused
and willing to let them die he took
action those are my
men my brothers not evidence
isaiah rescued the soldiers but was
punished for his heroism
imprisoned for 30 years and subjected to
experimental tests
with the help of a nurse isaiah faked
his death and escaped
and his history was buried if isaiah's
story sounds familiar
it's because it mirrors steve rogers
rescue of bucky and his troops from a
hydra base in captain america
the first avenger like isaiah steve
disobeyed orders to save the lives of
his fellow soldiers
unlike isaiah however he was promoted
for his actions
rather than thrown in prison and erased
from history this highlights the
deep-rooted racial injustice isaiah was
subjected to
and how differently he was treated as a
black man
in the end only sam can decide who he is
and whether he wants to be captain
america
other characters like isaiah bradley and
bucky might influence his decision
but ultimately it's sam who decides to
start training with the shield
preparing to take up the mantle steve
handed him unlike john walker sam was
chosen personally by steve due to the
merit of his character bucky admits to
some drawing truth
that neither he or steve considered what
it would mean for a black man to be
captain america prompting sam to lay
some hard truths of his own
you gotta stop looking to other people
to tell you who you are this line is as
relevant to some situation as it is to
buckies
bucky can't let other people decide his
identity for him anymore
he's more than 100 years old at this
point it's time for him to start
deciding for himself
likewise sam isn't willing to let
history's prejudices determine whether
he can be captain america
when his nephews are playing with the
shield we see the world sam wants to
help create
a world where young black boys can be
captain america if they want to
isaiah bradley's story should never be
forgotten but sam is now a part of
making a better future
but learns from the mistakes of the past
proving that steve rogers made the right
decision in passing the shield to him
at the beginning of episode 6 batch rock
the lieber gets what he's been waiting
for since episode 1
a chance to face sam one on one adorned
in his new captain america uniform sam
runs into batroc and the latter
expresses his frustration
over sam having cost him a lot of money
shortly after he mumbles the line
the robes don't make the monk it was a
blink in your missing moments as the
subtitles were barely on the screen for
a second
the line carries a whole lot of weight
and it's a variation of a popular
william shakespeare line
the cowl does not make the monk batroc
is essentially shading sam in this
moment
who's just officially become captain
america while looking at his new getup
the villain is telling him that just
because he puts on the uniform
that doesn't make him worthy of carrying
the mantle this is especially
interesting given that batroc has once
gone toe to toe with steve rogers
in captain america the winter soldier on
the hostage-filled shield ship
it looks like bacharach might have had a
little more respect for our first
captain america
and not so much for our newest one in
episode 6 carly distracts bucky with a
phone call in an effort to gather
hostages from the grc without his
interference
bucky who should have been smarter than
this falls for carly's trick
but the two end up having a pretty
poignant conversation despite carly not
really listening to her foe
but he gives carly a stern talking to
telling her that though she thinks her
cause might justify her
actions in the end the nightmares won't
go away we know this to be true as bucky
suffered from nightmares in episode 1
ones that he lied about to his therapist
but the line to her that follows turns
out to be one of the most personal of
missions bucky could have made
whether cardi realized it or not you're
gonna remember all the ones you killed
while this might seem like a piece of
advice shared with carly in an effort to
get her to stand down
it's actually a major call back to
captain america civil war
in the final battle between iron man
captain america and bucky
we hear a powerful variation of the line
when the vengeance fueled tony has bucky
in a headlock
do you even remember them i remember all
of them but he clearly understands the
dangerous path that carly is on
and it's serious repercussions but
unfortunately she doesn't listen
and she meets her end at the hands of
sharon while battling sam
when carly and sam are fighting one
another the latter takes a pretty decent
beating from the enhanced super soldier
even though sam has new tech and the
shield carly still seems to have the
upper hand against him
and she swiftly knocks him to the ground
more than once however
carly doesn't want to hurt sam and gives
him an opportunity to walk away
stay down
no you might have picked up on it and
kudos if you did
because this was another major callback
to captain america civil war
once bucky gets knocked down steve and
tony go one-on-one in a heartbreaking
battle
tony gets the upper hand after friday
analyzes cap's fight pattern
and he knocks steve down to the ground
stay down
final warning after rising steve
responds with his classic retort
i could do this all day this itself was
obviously a throwback to captain america
the first avenger
when a tiny steve spoke the line to a
bully in an alley who knew all these
years later would be referencing the
famous moment yet again
but in a way that's unique to sam writer
malcolm spellman could have easily had
sam say
i can do this all day back to kali we
all know the mcu isn't shy about
dropping that quote
but by giving him a different line it
gave him a separate identity from steve
something crucial to his character's
story because as the falcon and the
winter soldier has shown us in its six
episodes
we don't need another steve rogers as
captain america
we need a sam wilson check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the marvel
cinematic universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one